[Music]
joel is with us in cleveland ohio hey
joel what's up
what's going on dave so i'm kind of a
new uh listener um so
i wanted to give you a call so i'm
getting married in three weeks
congratulations
thank you very very much
my fiance and i have been living
together for the last year
we've we've tried different budgets
we've we've tried different ways
different
different websites nothing seems to
quite work we kind of end up just
a race to zero we've got a
combined income of about a hundred
thousand dollars
i've got about 5 000 in credit card debt
she's got about 3 000 in credit card
debt
um
we've got 4 000 savings and i've got
about 20 000 in mutual funds
okay car debt any car debt
no no car debt student loan
so she's got about 20
000 in student loans okay
all right
cool i do not and
um typically there's two things that
cause people to not be able to stick to
a budget
one is uh that they're using a wrong
technique which we can help you with
two is
they're not really committed to the idea
in other words if you write it down on
paper and have no intention of actually
doing what you wrote down
then guess what you're not going to do
what you wrote down
yeah since combining you know you know
combined like a bank
i just feel like we've had less control
and it's i guess it's
harder to
pay for two than
pay for one and it just
seems like a lot quicker to zero than it
used to be
this is extra confusing i mean if you've
got multiple incomes coming in you
should only have more
there versus less but we recommend a
zero-based budget and i don't know if
you've checked out every dollar it
doesn't sound like you have that's our
budgeting tool and i will gift that to
you guys as a wedding present uh
including ramsey plus so you'll have
access to all the videos inside of
financial piece but once you start your
every dollar budget it's super easy we
want to list out all of your income and
then we're going to list out all of your
expenses and when you subtract that
particular month
and when you subtract the expenses from
the income it should equal zero meaning
you've assigned every single dollar a
job we don't want any of your dollars
unemployed and once you do that and then
by the way you have to stick to it and
actually track it and go how much money
do we have for food when we go grocery
shopping then we're going to stick to
that budget and that's how you're going
to get that control but i can write down
a workout plan every weekday if and if i
never work out i'll never get in shape
yeah so get you assign every dollar a
mission every dollar a name that's why
we call the app every dollar both of you
look at that
before the month begins it's unique to
each month because every month is
different
okay
okay and then once you've assigned every
dollar both of you look at it both of
you make changes until every dollar has
a name
no extra slush money laying around every
dollar is assigned all the income you
have coming in net that month to work
with is assigned to something then it's
it's it's assigned to something both of
you agree with the assignments you agree
with the mission
and then you pinky swear and spit shake
this becomes a freaking contract that
says if we're not going to spend more
than
x number of dollars on restaurants then
by god stay home don't go to the
restaurant
you're contracting with each other we're
not going to spend more than this on
clothes this month i don't care if the
purse is on sale
we agreed to make that
extra trip to target we agreed that this
is what we were going to spend
don't lie to me
that's what you're saying to each other
you're contracting you have to make it a
very serious relational commitment
that's why both of you need a vote in
the formation of the thing
because otherwise you're bossing her
around or she's bossing you around
becomes a weapon but instead you're as a
couple saying our goals are x and the
best way to achieve our goals is this
list of expenditures
this month and we're not going to do
something other than that unless
something really nasty bad happens and
then we have to come back together and
together decide on how we're going to
change our budget before we do it you
don't come home from target you don't
come home from the grocery store you
don't come home from happy hour and go
well honey look what i did that's not
cute
that's childish
and that's the thing where i'm talking
about you committing to sticking to the
plan but laying out the technique that
the technique is every dollar has an
assignment as george said that's called
a zero-based budget the two of you
coming together
and agreeing that this is what we're
gonna do that's the technique now
typically we always say joel you said
you're new to this stuff we always tell
folks typically a married couple one of
you is more of a nerd that's into the
details and one of you is more of a free
spirit that's less into the details and
isn't going to think this is fun and the
nerd thinks doing the budget is like
great fun
correct okay
yeah that would be normal that the nerd
calls and asks this question
okay how do we do a budget free spirits
don't ask this question she's at target
right now yeah
so there we go
that's we figured it out yeah she's
getting her nails done right now so uh
but you know in my house i'm the nerd my
wife's the free spirit and so
same as at your house joel so what we
have to do is this nerds need free
spirits in their life so they have a
life
free spirits need nerds in their life so
they don't retire and have to eat alpo
correct so that that you need each other
if if two people just like get married
one's unnecessary so we need to be we
need each other you need to be working
off of each other's strengths both of
you have a vote this is a coming
together of a value system it's not you
bossing her around her bossing you
around you're not the boss of me and
this is a marriage two to three months
to get dialed in so don't give up if the
first one you go oh we couldn't do it
let's give up we can't do a budget stick
to it and kelly will pick up we'll gift
you guys a year of ramsay plus which
includes every dollar our premium
budgeting tool let us know how it goes